this is the drag to kids to pride event
organizers promoted it as a
family-friendly drag show it's glitter
it's fun and it's a show it's all for a
great cause it's a g-rated drag show
coming out of the closet means when you
tell everybody
that you're gay it's something that gay
people have to do desmond you're one of
the youngest and first drag queen slash
kids
it's come to a world where drag kids
actually exist and people do ketamine on
a couch
and they all go marching in the big
um
kids
what's that
i was talking to the owner's wife and
she said explicitly that there are
children in there
they've given everybody a wristband for
uh
under 21 and over 21.
drag shows that brand themselves as
child friendly or all ages welcome have
been popping up
across the country from palm springs to
dallas so we all know it was only a
matter of time before one showed up in
suburbia usa and that's exactly what
happened this past weekend in roanoke
texas
newly opened anderson distillery and
grill decided to get in on this underage
action and host their own child friendly
that's the keyword here child friendly
drag show on sunday august 28th of
course this raised some concerns online
especially in the conservative-minded
roanoke i mean close-minded cretans so
the owner took to facebook in advance to
assure everyone that the drag
performances would be positively pg
john hughes asked
now of course while i had absolutely
zero reason to not believe this drag
show would be pg as advertised as a
reputable journalistic outfit i wanted
to make sure that i and my team was
doing all of our due diligence so i sent
them out undercover as specialists to
get them not so skinny on the drag show
and see exactly how kid-friendly
it was over here my team's findings were
well uh
just watch
how are y'all doing
how's it going doing all right
getting hurt
wow it's gonna be a busy day
you guys got your own personal security
surprisingly the first thing that
greeted my team outside of the
distillery sorry child friendly
distillery that was hosting the drag
show was the overabundance of strapped
to the gills black block and antifa
members surrounding said establishment
nothing says child friendly like people
decked out in tactical gear and pride
flags
but my team needn't worry fbi director
christopher wray assured us that antifa
is not a group it's nothing more than an
ideology we look at antifa as more of an
ideology or a movement
than an organization
you all doing all right
i'm not trying to start anything
we just want to see what's going on what
brought you out
so
it seems that we're not being welcomed
into here we're not trying to start
stuff say that seems like a pretty
organized ideology after all though it's
hard to believe that 30 individuals
showed up to the same event dressed in
the same clothes and all following the
exact same blueprint only thing missing
is the gay gang signs
okay well you're free to protest is
america so please continue to do so i
cannot get a response from anybody
i don't know we're just trying to talk
to people but it seems that none of them
want to talk
or anything like that you can look at
here i'll give you the website
what is it unt
blogs dot art dot blog
yeah blogs
yes
now in the spirit of balance i would be
remiss if i didn't point out the counter
protesters uh who also looked extremely
intimidating what's going on here
[Applause]
what are the rules with the protest just
so we're clear on everything i mean just
everybody stay on their side and so far
it's it's been good you know as long as
you know they stay there they stay there
that's fine are those actual weapons
that they have strapped on they look
real
it's legal to have it is texas yeah the
only time we've had issues today is when
people migrate over to one side so
yeah so he's basically saying just every
side needs to stay on their side i know
that's probably not actually what the
legality of the constitution says but it
probably makes the most sense for what's
going on
um we have some people
trying to start stuff the cops roll
through the cops rolled out i don't know
we'll be here let's hope nothing pops
off too much i went over there to talk
to somebody i knew right
and all of a sudden i get like seven or
eight of them come up to me seven or
eight of them come up to me get over
here
get off this property every day we
should wake up and say how can we make
our country better
but my whole thought process is let me
have freedom of my speech too
you know if somebody wants to change my
ways i'll listen to anybody but you know
what show me the respect to listen to my
opinion this is okay you know what i
don't have a problem with it but all
this is right here
they're just trying to get a tick-tock
view because i've been praying to a god
of miracles it takes a miracle to change
a heart your people are crazy don't
wanna kill us all so no you do you do
all i can do is pray what did you come
out to do to talk to people
i hope you all right
get this out of here before we pick you
up
what are they doing
at least it was just water yeah it's
just water it's fine it's fine we'll
bring y'all out here today
who's your people we're we don't know
where
okay what is happening in here why
are there antifa i assume antifa
protesters with guns and anti-protest
counter protesters over there why
so it's a drag show and the man who owns
this distillery his son is a drag queen
okay you want to be gay you want to drag
me go go for it you're not her but
adults but don't involve a little
eight-year-old girl that you you tell
susie who's 11. susie you need a double
mastectomy because you really want to be
a boy susie doesn't know she wants to be
a boy or not yet puberty blockers
right what we're hearing from over there
is that the child angle they're saying
this is a sexualization of minors
opening up children to things that they
should not be seeing i think they just
don't know the full story because this
is not about this is not about children
this is not about opening their eyes to
this and making them see this it's about
support for his family
really
is that really what's happening inside
though and i teach middle school so like
it's important for my kids to know no i
love you because tomorrow you love him
and then you love her and you're going
to love a tree the next day we brought
our kids we're like this is something
good for them
how old are your kids like 11 today oh
my god i fought in the army for 23 years
60 points so that y'all can do what you
do and i can do but don't involve
children is all i'm saying just keep the
children out of it are there children in
there i haven't been in there i don't
think so
if there are they're with their families
and they're just enjoying a great time
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
clearly it's fun for the whole family
approved for all ages are there children
inside yeah there's three or four of
them but these girls are all fully
closed this is a pg performance like
it's for it's family friendly
well i mean i think it's just a
lifestyle well
crap
it's almost as if sexualization is the
entire goal again good wholesome
family-friendly fun here's what nida
montana tweeted out just two days after
the event
you know the town had their complaints
you know there were some people that
were very angry it's just it's one of
those things that you know and most of
these people don't live here a lot of
the businesses here owned by the people
in trophy club but uh yeah i mean it's
always been conservative because of that
like they were telling us earlier this
is the first show of the kind that
that's like that here
[Music]
i didn't know roanoke a city could be
gay it's it's i'm sorry but it's
inanimate
[Music]
they said when you're 18 do what you
want but they're saying if you're under
18 this is they shouldn't be here i
don't know in my opinion i don't think
it's weird but i guess people can have
their opinions but it's just like kind
of disrespectful to
scream at people
what they're saying is that there's
children in here and this is sexual
exposing children to sexual content and
that is
should not be happening sexual happening
in here
[Music]
what's the difference between that and a
children's beauty pageant that's
actually sexualizing children i'm not
exactly sure
you'd want to make that comparison but
do as you will did anybody ever watch
mrs doubtfire and enjoy that did anybody
ever watch there's tons of things on the
tv it's not this is not this is like a
comedy show like like that
i think when it uh whenever there's like
a
like a sexual thing going on should
there shouldn't be kids there now my
team wanted to get more information
about what the show's supporters
thought in regards to what constitutes
sexual content or what have you but
every time we got to that point in the
conversation the goon squad that's
totally not an organization just an
ideology mind you stepped in
it's usually best
oh sorry
i'm being pulled away y'all have fun and
thank you for speaking with us
appreciate it
luckily for us not everyone was against
explaining their views that guy in the
gray shirt over there i've been praying
for him most today he's under quite a
conviction right now
and it may not happen today
but his heart will be changed
and because i've been praying to a god
of miracles it takes a miracle to change
a heart
i can't do it all i can do is pray and
he said if you were willing to have a
face-to-face conversation he would do
the same thing
would that be something you'd be willing
to do
okay i know how those people feel about
me and they put a bullet in my head
i promise you i was not well you're
strong in your son yes sir oh well let's
see how this goes there's no g-strings
or anything like that there's no
child abuse going on at all inside in
your heart
you can tell me the children need to be
taught
this in your heart my heart i can tell
you that there's an openness to this
yeah do you believe that children should
be
hit with this in classrooms
should it be taught trench yesterday i
don't believe children are taught that
in classrooms and i teach middle school
so like it's important for my kids to
know
not great so far i'm gonna break this
guy's heart hey you don't have to pray
for me i have to it'll change i promise
you it may be in a dream tonight we're
gonna not agree on that everyone you
know women in leadership i'm gonna
continue to pray i'm sure you believe
that nancy pelosi also doesn't believe
in belonging a leadership position so
thank you very much for talking all
right both of you good to see you i
don't know what's going to happen here
so i just don't want anybody to be here
hey thank you again this has nothing to
do with why i'm here
well why are you here that i'm praying
for you why i don't need prayer sir i am
good my relationship with god
my relationship with god is completely
on my own i hate the fact that you
probably have cheated on your wife
multiple times
i hate that i hate that for you i hate
that problem i hate the fact that your
wife was probably cheated on you
multiple times you know what you've been
what married 60 years probably
i'm sure there's been some infidelity
there
you are not perfect in your marriage
pray for me all you want the book of
james is my favorite book god jesus the
holy man everything i have a
relationship with him your people are
crazy don't want to kill us all so
[Music]
how do you do fellow kids
over there we're not listening listen
of course it wasn't long before the
police got involved
do i look cool
oh so that's what this is all about hi
beto i mean robert francis just make
sure that we shined a light on this
loving family so their fellow texans
understand what's at stake i actually
appreciate the full disclosure here when
you go out to vote in november and you
think of beto o'rourke
think this child-friendly drag show
and just like beto's rally in livingston
most of the people with whom we spoke
were not even from the area
they just came in for the event they
were imported but you don't have to take
my word for it to further illustrate
that fact the mayor of roanoke released
a statement and personally emailed this
to my team expressing
the reaction and outrage from the
roanoke community we will do whatever it
takes i think that's what he sounds like
we will do whatever it takes working
with our county and state partners to
maintain a culture of respect for
families and in defense of our children
having heard from our residents rest
assured that the city is investigating
the incident and is pursuing all options
to ensure our children are protected and
the safety of our community is not
compromised
by now it should be clear that nothing
that took place in roanoke was family
friendly and at its core
this entire charade is nothing more than
a method to indoctrinate children
into a perverse ideology
at its worst at best and show them
hyper-sexualized content that would
never be allowed with underage children
in a heterosexual strip club but the
progressive left is not backing down
they are demanding that you comply if
you choose to do so that's your right
but i do want you
to remember one thing if you remember
nothing else
from this segment it's when you think
the democratic party and particularly
beto robert francis o'rourke
think
child-friendly drag shows